I'm loud.
Oh my gosh, I'm so loud.
Hello, everybody.
Hello.
Can you guys hear me?
I don't know if I'm loud or not.
I don't know.
Hello?
Okay, give me a sec.
Oh my god, to listen to BGM, but I don't want to listen to BGM.
Hello?
Wait, I got an idea.
Maybe if I... Okay, so I'm not forced to listen to BGM, but you are.
Okay, hello.
Okay, where's my chat?
Okay, here we go.
Oh, everything is so scuffed right now.
Everything is so scuffed.
I couldn't... I'm updating my phone to see if I can get my skin suit on.
But right now, I'm just a... There is no BGM.
There's no way.
I worked so hard sitting on it.
Is there actually no BGM?
Can you guys not hear this?
In the background?
Can you... Oh, is it crispy?
Moist.
Okay, I'll up the BGM.
Okay, SoundGat, you gotta Discord message me because...
Um... Because I can't see shit.
Oh, am I peeking the mic?
Oh, no.
Okay, let me tone it down a little.
Let me... I'm at the... If you guys didn't know... Hello?
Hello?
Yo, I am at the... Uh... Marvel Rivals studio right now.
So, like... Yeah, like...
I was here an hour early.
And I still couldn't fucking figure out how to set this up.
I...
I said...
I woke up at 6 in the morning.
Got breakfast.
Came over here.
And, um...
And, like, you know...
Like...
Just try to set up this PC.
Uh...
So, if any of my sound people...
I can't even tweet out that I'm live right now.
Um...
Because I'm trying to update my phone.
And I didn't log on to my Twitter on the PC.
So, like...
I was like, oh, maybe my phone needs an update.
And that's why, like, my skin suit stuff don't work.
Um...
Because I have to connect via USB.
And it's like...
Okay, here's some technical...
Oh, am I peaking the mic really bad?
I'll put it farther away from me.
There you go.
I'm sorry.
I'm...
I'm figuring stuff as we go along.
I...
The mic is...
Like, really far away from my face now.
Is that better?
Is it better?
No, you're...
Wait, where did I put my water?
Also, I got sick.
I literally got sick on the day I was gonna stream.
I was okay.
And then, uh...
Uh...
Oh, am I low now?
God, fucking okay.
Um...
I'll boost up myself.
But I put the mic away from me.
But, um...
Yeah, I'm...
Today...
The day I decided to stream, I got sick in the end.
I think it's because, like, I'm going through, like, hot and cold environments.
Like, it'll be, like, super hot outside.
For those who don't know!
Okay, I'll explain more.
As soon as you guys, like, tell me if everything sounds okay.
Um...
Let me know.
If you tell me...
Whenever my volume, my mic stuff is, like, okay.
Just let me know.
And then I'll tell the story.
Oh...
No, it's, like...
Super hot, humid environment.
And then I go into a super cold environment.
And then back and forth.
So, like, that's not very good for your body.
I don't know if you guys know that.
They even warned us, too.
They're, like, if you get, like, extra, like, super hot.
And then move into a super cold environment.
And do it, like, back and forth.
You're more likely to get sick.
Because your body is not good at, you know, adjusting to the different temperatures.
Um...
Uh...
Okay.
I don't know if any of my sound people are alive.
Because I don't...
I don't know.
Alright.
Are any of my mods alive?
Because I can't start the story until we figure this shit out, guys.
I can't start any of my stories.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
One of them was, like, I'm sort of here.
I'm...
I don't know how much that's gonna help.
But they're sort of here.
You know?
I don't know.
Why am I also, like...
Yeah.
It's a lot.
Everything is...
I think I spent, like, an hour and 15 minutes just trying to fix my...
Like, trying to see if I can...
Um...
If I could, like, get my skin suit to work.
But I guess that...
I wasted an hour and 15 minutes of my life.
I...
I guess.
Okay.
Wait.
Let me see.
All right.
Let's see if this connects via USB.
Oh, well.
Never mind.
I have to download and update first.
For my...
For my VTube studios.
All right.
Oh, it's...
Oh, it's picking up Discord.
Bling.
Sorry.
If you guys are hearing notifications.
Um...
That was from my sound team.
They're like...
Bling.
Wait.
Can I...
I need to set up streamer mode, too.
I guess.
Oh.
Where's streamer mode?
It's not automatic?
Where's my streamer mode?
Not automatic.
Okay.
Streamer mode.
Oh.
I think it's, like...
Where was here last turn?
Not streamer mode.
That's why.
That makes sense.
Bling.
All right.
Notifications are off.
You guys won't be tortured by the...
Um...
By the notifications now.
All right.
I'm just waiting for them to tell me if everything's gonna be okay.
Don't worry, Toki.
Everything's gonna be okay.
Even though I...
I...
I don't feel like it.
But everything's gonna...
Be okay.
Hehehehehe.
All right.
Let's see if this works.
Connect to USB.
Come on.
Why don't you work?
Work.
Oh my god.
I worked so hard.
Okay.
Updating my phone was not it.
I thought updating my phone would fix it.
But it didn't fix anything.
All right.
Because they were like...
Oh, maybe it's because your phone isn't updated.
And maybe when you update your phone, it will be okay.
I was like, okay.
When was the last time I updated?
And I was like...
I had to delete stuff off my phone.
Because the update was too big.
So I had to like...
I had to like...
Delete like 10 gigabytes worth of stuff on my phone.
And to get to like my new iPhone update.
So I was like, okay, I did that.
I just deleted like 10 gigabytes of stuff.
Maybe then it will work.
Maybe then the world will be kind to me.
Um, but sadly that was a lie.
That...
Yeah, because my phone is like maxed out in...
Um, my phone has like...
Is maxed out in memory stuff.
Um, because I've been transferring my files since I first got an iPhone.
Which is the iPhone 1.
So, um...
I haven't deleted anything since then.
So I have like stuff from like...
I don't know.
Whenever the iPhone 1 first came out.
I still have stuff from that.
Like on my phone.
And I've just been like transferring it.
Over and over.
Like just like the next generation.
Next generation.
Like over and over and over again.
Until like, you know.
Instead of like deleting anything.
I just...
I just buy a bigger...
I just buy more gigabytes.
You see.
When I first started.
It was like what?
8 gigabytes I think.
I think that was like the original.
It was 8 gigabytes.
And then, you know.
After that they made 32.
And then after 32.
They made like 64.
And then 128.
So I just...
I just kept...
Um...
I just kept like upgrading.
More and more.
I just keep...
I just keep adding more data.
Because if...
Instead of deleting...
Uh...
Deleting...
More...
Deleting any of my stuff.
I just add more.
I'm hearing a buzz in the background.
It could just be the air con.
My sound guy is like...
Um...
Saying like...
Oh, I'm hearing a buzz.
It could be the air con.
I don't fucking know.
There's a...
I'm like...
I'm like in my own room.
For this.
Alright, let's try one more time.
Connect to USB.
I can't do it via Wi-Fi for some reason.
So I have to do it via...
Connect via USB.
But it's still...
Oh my gosh.
It's still not connecting.
I guess we'll...
Maybe I need like an official iPhone cable.
And I don't have that.
Maybe that's why...
Oh, whatever.
We'll just be a PNG.
We'll figure this out one day.
Um...
Is it the mic?
You hear it?
I don't know.
Do you guys actually hear it?
I feel like it's the air con.
Maybe I'll do like...
This?
Uh...
Is it the air con?
It could be the air con.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
It's fine.
Like, this is the way it is.
Okay, so they actually have a different room.
But because it's the launch of the new...
Uh...
It's the launch of the new season.
Um...
The actual streaming rooms are taken right now.
And...
So like...
Because there's an actual like...
They have like a little...
It's so crazy.
Okay, so...
Okay.
So for those who don't know...
I'm currently in Guangzhou right now in China.
Uh...
Because that is where the Marvel Rivals Studio is.
So I'm literally in China right now.
That's why I'm like...
I have to wake up at 6 in the morning.
I...
So...
That's where they're...
Okay.
So the Marvel Rivals Studio is actually in two different areas.
They have campuses in...
Um...
Different places.
Okay.
It's literally public information.
Like...
The literally...
Marvel Rivals First Land...
Is in Guangzhou.
Like it's everywhere.
Like...
What do you mean fucking...
Don't dox yourself.
Like...
It's like literally...
If you Google...
Marvel Rivals Studio...
It's like...
Guangzhou.
How do I fucking hide that?
How do I...
How do I fucking hide that shit?
Anyway.
So...
It's actually crazy.
Because...
Um...
They have...
Four campuses...
Across Guangzhou.
And then you know how like...
Okay.
So like in NA...
Um...
You know when you go to like a studio?
It's like in one building.
Right?
But like...
Here?
It was like a fucking university campus.
So like you go to...
There's like different buildings...
For different like...
Um...
Uh...
Areas.
But it was like one out of four campuses...
Around...
Um...
Uh...
Around Guangzhou.
So...
And they also have some in Hangzhou too.
So it was...
They have like...
It's like their own little university campus.
So they'll have like...
A coffee shop.
They'll have like stores.
They'll have like pharmacies.
And stuff like that.
They have like...
A giant-ass cafeteria building and everything.
It's crazy.
They also have peacocks.
I'll show you a picture of them.
Because apparently... Also, SoundGuy, let me know if I need to lower my mic.
So, apparently, their CEO of NetEase... By the way, Marble Rival Studio is like...
The company that makes it is NetEase.
And they're one of the biggest game companies in China.
But anyway, the NetEase CEO believes in Feng Shui.
So, basically, the reason why there's...
There's basically a bunch of random animals in different campuses.
And one of the staff took me to the peacock area.
Because the Feng Shui master told them...
If you put peacocks in your campus, you'll be more lucky for the company.
So, they literally have a peacock area.
And the funny thing is that they're all men.
I was like, wait, where are the female peacocks?
They're all men.
And then the staff was like, wait, how do you can tell?
Because, like, male peacocks are the ones with the flashy feathers.
You know, the blue peacocks.
And then, like, the females are, like, brown.
So, like, um...
But yeah, they have, like, a fucking peacock area.
It was so cool.
Yeah, they're, like, um...
Uh, they're...
But yeah, apparently it was, like, for Feng Shui and stuff.
Because, like, I don't know if you ever...
Because, like, my mom was, like, obsessed with Feng Shui.
So, like, I know a lot about it.
Um, but I thought it was very interesting.
Like, how the campus was designed to optimize Feng Shui.
Um...
Uh...
Yeah, the boys only club.
Yeah, it was just all men.
I was, like, where are the ladies here?
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Uh...
But yeah, no, I'm so...
I'm so tired, though.
Like, I have...
I wanted to stream at, still, like, an NA time.
But, yeah, it took a lot of sacrifice.
Okay, so, for those who don't know, I was invited by the, uh, Marvel Rivals Studio slash NetEase To, uh, fly out of Guangzhou.
To, like, you know, get a little tour of... Oh my gosh, it's been so long since I've streamed.
I don't even know how to talk anymore.
I... Oh wait, I can do it live now!
Let me, give me a sec, let me tweet that out that I'm live now.
But, like, I can't really, um, do the... share it on Twitter.
I'll just quote retweet myself and be like, live now!
So I'm bouncing all over the place.
I'm, like, actually all over the place right now.
I forgot how to stream.
Um, but I've been very incognito.
So, also, like, only the staff sort of know.
Like, only the staff... So, for those who don't know, there's a lot of people here.
There's, like, um, you know, other content creators here that they invited.
Um, and, um, other, you know, players and everything.
But the great thing about me is that I can blend in.
Because, you know, like, I'm Chinese.
That's... That's the best part.
So, like, I just look like a staff member while I walk around.
Yeah, so, like, I don't have to worry.
I...
The best is guys.
Um, but I don't talk.
Okay.
And then, the best thing is that I've actually been speaking Chinese with the staff, too.
Because, like, um, for those who don't know, people, um, uh, people in Guangzhou speak Cantonese.
And then, so, I've just been speaking Cantonese with all the staff members.
I've been hanging out with them.
And, like, we've been gossiping and stuff.
We've been... We've been gossiping.
And, uh, like, I've had, like, dinners with the staff, too.
So, like, we would just all, like, get together.
And, like, you know, after... After Latin.
And we just, like, gossip and, like, have beer.
And, like, I actually had beer with the staff.
And we were just hanging out and, like, talking in Chinese.
I'm basically staff, yeah, yeah.
Okay, so, wait, let me tweet out that I'm live.
Bureau clock, yeah.
It's been fun, though.
It's been really fun, like, interacting with, like, I like to say interacting with everyone, but, like, interacting with the staff.
I have not talked to anybody else.
I've mostly been talking to staff, because I've been, like, you know, like, incognito, like, ooh.
Apparently, um, um, some of, I've, from what I've heard, some of the players were like, wait, Doki Bird is here?
And, like, apparently, one, like, I don't remember which social media manager, but the social media manager requested if I could, like, give them an autograph.
After I posted, tweeted out that, like, it was, like, one of the eSport team's social media managers, and they, like, requested from the staff if, like, like, if they could get my autograph or something, because they're, like, wait, she's here?
Like, I'm...
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I was, like, perfect disguise.
I'm Chinese.
Perfect.
No one will expect anything.
Okay, wait, let me tweet out that I'm live real quick.
No worries.
The only issue is that I cannot read.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, wait.
Okay.
I know I'm, like, jumping all over it, because I have so many things I want to tell you guys, but, uh, okay.
Uh, buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh.
Uh, okay, so apparently the sound guy was like, we gotta do something with your compressor later, but for now, um, we'll fix that later.
Don't worry, I'm just doing one stream, and then I'm out.
And then I'll do my, and then my next stream will be back home.
I just wanted to, like, talk about a little bit of my trip, and then the next stream I'll be back home.
I also miss you guys.
I hope you guys didn't forget who I am.
I am in Versaunt.
I'm sorry, it's the aircon.
It's so fucking hot.
It's so fucking hot outside.
Uh, it's the aircon.
It's, it's like that, sadly.
I'm sorry about the buzzing.
Um, okay, let me tweet out that I'm live.
Is the buzzing, like, super annoying, or is it okay?
Uh, it's fine?
Okay, I'm trying to...
Oh, Twitter's so slow.
I'm trying to tweet out that I'm here.
But, like, okay, whatever.
You guys can... Oh my gosh, wait, no, I should do it.
Alright, uh, it's not that bad.
Okay, I'm gonna use my data real quick so I can just tweet out that I'm here.
I'm, I'm live.
I'm gonna use my data super quick just for that.
I think I'm gonna be paying a lot of money on my data.
Because I want faster internet.
My data is the fastest.
Live!
Now!
Alright.
There you go.
I did it.
Okay, and then I put back my Wi-Fi.
Okay.
Oh.
What was I gonna say?
Okay.
Um.
I'll explain the story later.
But.
Every time.
Okay, so it's been so long since I spoke or, like, I guess, like, listened to Chinese.
Both Mandarin and Cantonese.
So, like, um, whenever, like, I don't know what the fuck you're saying to me.
I'd be like,
I'm sorry, I'm Canadian.
I've been, I've been using that excuse everywhere.
Every time I don't know what they're saying, I just be like, I'm sorry, I'm Canadian.
And then it works every time.
They'll be like, oh, okay.
And they'll, like, treat me like a child because I don't know what they're saying.
Because, like, there's some words, there's some words that I don't know what they're saying at all.
So I was just like, oh, I'm sorry.
And it works.
So I just be like, oh.
Because, like, if we're ordering food or if we're paying and I don't know what they're saying, I'm just like, I'm sorry, I'm Canadian.
So, it's just... So, it works.
It works every time.
And then, like, try it through, like, oh, I understand.
I understand.
We gotta treat this one like a child.
I'm like, yay!
Using the Canadian card.
Cause, like, okay.
I'll tell you guys why.
Okay, so.
So, it's been eight years since I've been in China.
I think.
I don't know.
Maybe more.
So, those eight years, a lot have changed.
It's crazy.
It's actually crazy how everything changed in eight years.
And one of the biggest changes is that they don't accept cash or credit cards anymore.
And, like, I don't...
So, everything has to be done by... by paid, like, electronically by, like, um, a chat thing called WeChat.
Or Alipay.
Mostly.
So, yeah.
It's all QR codes.
That's why, like, you see, like, in, like, Asian streaming sites, everybody uses QR codes.
Cause it's so integrated into society.
But not for, like, NA.
Cause we're, like, we... we're, like, what the fuck is a QR code?
We're...
They're, like, why are we... why do we need to scan a QR code for shit?
Um...
So, yeah.
So, they don't accept cash or they don't accept credit card.
So, sometimes, um, we have to scan a QR code to, like, look... get a menu.
So, like, when I'm, like, walking around, I'm, like, walking around by myself to, like, restaurants.
Like, when I walked around to my first restaurant, I didn't realize that, like, even menus are now QR codes.
And it, like... and when you scan a QR code, like, you don't get a physical menu.
When you scan a QR code, it directs you straight to an app.
And, like, the thing is, I'm using data.
So, because I'm not connected to Chinese internet, or, like, a Chinese data plan, or, I don't know, Chinese Wi-Fi, my data plan, which is Canadian, can't connect to the menu app.
I can't... I can't connect to the app.
Because I need... I need, like, a Chinese internet plan to, like, access it.
Yeah.
So... so... yeah.
And...
Um...
So, I was so confused.
I was, like, oh, no.
I should have got... I should have got an internet plan when I came here.
By the way, my decision to accept the invitation was so last-minute.
Literally, like, you know, when I was, like, guys, I'm gonna go on a vacation.
Two, like, like, like, um, when I... after the Fate Trigger tournament, I'm like, yippee, vacation starts tomorrow.
The day before that tournament, I decided to go to China.
Like...
So, I...
Needless to say, I didn't prepare a lot for this trip.
I was not... I was not prepared.
I was not ready at all for a 14-hour-plus journey.
Um...
Dookie, please.
It's my first day as a submarine captain.
Okay.
Anyway.
So, um, um...
So, when I tried to scan the app, it, like, didn't lead me to anywhere.
Because, like, you have to use, like, um, the Chinese internet plan.
Like, like, it has to be Chinese internet.
It can't be, like, like, foreign countries.
Like, you know, like, because my plan was...
I'm using roaming data from Canada.
Uh, so I could, like, access Twitter because I'm brainwanted.
Um, and YouTube videos.
Anyway.
So, um...
So, I, like, the...
I, like, held a lady over.
Because, like, uh, I don't know if you guys know this, but, like, waiters aren't assigned to your tables in Asian countries.
So, you can hail anyone over.
So, I hailed a lady over.
And then she was, like, oh, just...
Because I was, like, can I have a menu?
And I was, like, because I don't know how to say menu in Chinese.
And...
So, she was, like, oh, you can scan the app.
And I was, like...
Well, she's not a darn.
I'm Canadian.
And then she gave me a physical menu.
It works every time.
It hasn't failed me yet.
And then she just gave me a physical menu.
And it was, like, oh, you just ticked this.
And then when you pay, they give you...
So, when they give you the receipt, there's, like, a QR code on the receipt.
So, when you pay for it, you scan the QR code.
And then it leads you to the app to pay.
Because, like, nothing... everything is digital now.
Like, you don't, like, have to, like...
You don't... you literally pay and you can just leave on your...
Like, you can pay on your phone and just leave.
And then, so, I was, like, okay.
Well, clearly, I can't do that.
So, I, like, held a waitress over.
And she was, like, oh, you can just come over here.
And I just... I just scanned my QR...
Because I have a QR code to my wallet now.
Because I use WeChat.
So, I have my QR code.
And I just scanned it.
Like, I had to, like, physically walk there and scan it.
And I'm, like, yay.
I don't have to, like, wash dishes.
Yeah, so, yeah, so, you know, it's been fun.
Oh, my gosh.
It's crazy.
Learning about...
Okay, so, I've been hanging out with a lot of the Marvel Rivals staff team.
Because, like, I just speak...
Because they're, like, oh, my God, you speak Cantonese?
And I was, like, yeah, I speak Cantonese.
Yeah, I grew up here, like, for 10 years.
So, like, I was, like, chatting with them.
And I was telling them about, like, you know, how everything's digital now.
Like, with WeChat.
Like, paying with WeChat and stuff like that.
And then one of the staff was, like...
Because I was just having a conversation with one of them.
And she was telling me how, like, oh, yeah.
Like, even, like, the homeless people.
When you, like...
When they, like, ask for money.
They, like...
They don't want cash.
They put out their QR code out.
And then you...
You give money via QR code.
I was, like, wait, are you...
You're not fucking with me, right?
I was, like, what?
Like, yeah.
I was, like, oh, my God.
I was, like, what?
Oh, you...
I was, like, oh, my God.
This is, like, a whole new world.
Um...
Yeah, so...
They have...
They use, like, QR code cheats and stuff, too.
They, like, have their QR codes printed out.
And you can give homeless people money by scanning the QR code and everything.
I was, like, holy shit.
I was, like, whoa.
Yeah, like, uh...
Because, like, nobody, like...
Because, like, no one uses cash anymore.
Like, no one really accepts cash.
Um...
Because, like, it's linked to your WeChat wallet or Alipay.
I think that...
Yeah, Alipay is the other one.
Um...
But I thought it was so interesting.
I was, like, what?
That's real?
And then she was, like, yeah, no, it's true.
It's actually true.
Um...
Oh, yeah.
And, like...
Okay, so...
Everything here...
Um...
Is, like, has its own app.
So there's no Uber here.
Because Uber is so fucking expensive in general.
So, like, um...
Uh...
Wake up, Samurai!
You got spare change to get...
Um...
Luca, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So, um...
It's, uh...
Oh, no, sorry.
I lost my train of thought.
I lost my...
What was I talking...
I'm sorry.
I'm all over the place.
It's been a while since I've streamed.
And it's been a while since I've, like, talked in English, too.
To be fair.
I've been talking in Chinese, like, majority of my time here.
Um...
Oh, yeah, sorry.
Uber is, like, super expensive.
So, um...
Um...
So, in China, they made their own app called Didi.
And, like, I was so confused at first.
Because, like, they're like, oh, can you book us a Didi?
And I was like, what the fuck is a Didi?
And then, like...
But that's basically Uber in China.
But, like, own...
Like, this, like...
Um...
It's an app for, like...
Uh...
For, like, Chinese citizens.
Um...
And...
So...
I...
Oh, my gosh.
I'm, like...
I feel like I'm getting robbed by Uber.
I...
Okay.
So...
It cost me, like, five RMB for, like, a six-minute drive.
Uh...
To, like...
Um...
To...
Like, for a six-minute drive.
Because, like, you know, from the hotel to the...
Uh...
From the hotel to the campus.
To a university campus.
And it cost six RMB...
Like, five to six RMB.
And for those who don't know how much that is...
That is 70 US cents.
That...
That is...
70 US cents.
Yeah.
And I'm, like, thinking...
Oh, my God.
I would have had to pay, like, seven fucking US dollars.
Yeah.
I was, like...
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
I would have had to pay...
70...
Do you...
Like, 70 RMB if I used Uber.
But there's not a lot of fees, though.
That's the thing.
I think the reason why it's so cheap is that they don't take a lot of fees, like Uber.
Um...
Uh...
Because there's ads on DD, too.
So, like, Uber, you don't really see ads.
But, um...
DD runs with ads, though.
So...
But, like...
I mean, I don't fucking care.
Five...
70 cents?
Give me all the ads you want.
Like...
I don't think I care.
Oh, my God.
Give me a commercial break if it's 70 cents.
Like...
But, yeah.
It's actually worth it.
Um...
But, yeah.
Because, like, Uber, it puts fees.
Like, you know.
Handling fee.
Tip fee.
Um...
Uh...
I don't know.
It gives me, like, three fucking fees.
I think DD had, like, zero fees.
Uh...
Anyway.
I could not care less for the ads, man.
I mean, that saves me fucking money.
I don't care.
I'll consume all your ads.
Sorry.
Um...
Anyway.
Oh, my gosh.
I wrote, like, all the stuff I want to...
I want...
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
So...
Um...
I'm so fucking stupid, too.
Because, like...
I forgot.
Like...
You know.
Like I said.
YouTube...
And, like, a lot of stuff is, like...
You can't really access here.
Um...
The reason why I'm here...
I'm able to is because, you know...
I'm at the studio.
But...
Um...
So, they have their own apps for a lot of things.
But I forgot.
Because, like, you know...
It's been eight years.
I used to use Google Maps all the time.
Even when I was here.
So...
But I forgot.
Like, now...
You don't use Google Maps anymore.
Alright.
So, this is leading to a story.
So...
One day...
Um...
The staff...
One of the staff members recommended me a really good restaurant.
So, I decided...
Okay.
I was gonna...
I'm gonna DD over there.
And then I'll walk back.
Because it seems really...
It was like...
Oh, I looked at my Google Maps.
And it was like...
You know...
It's like a...
14 minute walk or some shit.
And I was like...
I can do that.
And, like...
I'm so full.
It would be good to walk off all that meat inside me.
So, I was like...
Alright, Google Maps.
I'll follow you.
And then...
I kept walking.
And I kept walking.
And I was like...
This is long...
I feel like this is longer than 14 minutes.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
And then...
Finally...
I was getting close.
And then I was like...
It was like...
Your destination is here.
And I looked up...
And it was an empty lot filled with, like, a giant-ass empty lot where it's, like, construction and everything.
And I was like, what happened?
I was like, did they, like, smash down the hotel?
What happened?
This says I'm supposed to be at the hotel.
I was like, did, like, did my hotel got fucking sucked up by a UFO and then it's gone now?
Like, am I, while I was walking, was I, like, in an alternate dimension?
I accidentally walked through a, like, a time, like, a portal.
Like, it was, like, time portals or whatever where it transports me into, like, an alternate universe where the hotel never existed.
Doki.
It was, like, it was so fucking creepy, too, because it was literally, like, a giant empty lot where, like, they're building something.
Like, they're just starting construction.
So, so, it's, like, it was just, like, a giant empty fucking lot.
And there was, like, cranes and everything.
And I was so, I was actually panicking because I was, like, where did I go?
Like, what happened to the hotel?
Like, what happened within two hours?
Like, did, like, the building, like, got smashed down and I wasn't aware of it?
Like,
and so, like, so I kept walking.
So, I was, like, oh, maybe the hotel is just straightforward, like, and then I kept walking and then I saw a giant, like, lit up building.
I was, like, that has to be the hotel, right?
And I walked up to it.
It was not a hotel.
I don't even know what building it was.
But I was just so confused.
I was, like, where am I?
It says I'm here.
I don't understand.
My Google Maps says I'm here.
And then I had to, like, I had to, like, WeChat message one of the staff members.
And I was, like, SOS, I don't know where I am.
It's like, like, I don't know where I am.
My map says I'm here, but I'm not here.
And then they're, like, oh, share your location because you can do that on WeChat.
And then I shared my location.
And then, like, she was, like, wait, did you say Google Maps?
And I was, like, yeah.
And she was, like, we don't use that here.
We use something called do.
And I was, like, do?
And then they're, like, oh, you're actually, it's okay.
You're actually, like, like, ten, like, six minutes away from the hotel.
Like, you can, here's how, this is how you can walk over there.
I was, like, thank you.
I don't, thank you for saving me.
I was, like, and I was, like, oh, my God.
And apparently, and I turned left when I should have turned right.
And because, like, I had to go, like, a huge, giant loop around to get back to my hotel.
So, I went on a fucking adventure.
I, I, I, you have no idea how, I wish, I wish I took a picture of the construction lot.
Because you guys have no idea how fucking scared I was.
I was, like, did I, did I actually went through a fucking mini portal?
Like, there's, like, pocket dimensions accidentally.
I crossed through, like, this is, like, one in a million chance where a pocket dimension spawned.
And I walked right directly to it.
And then, like, the hotel was just not there anymore.
Like, I was, like, looking at my Google map.
It's, like, it says I'm there.
I was so confused.
It literally says I'm here.
Like, how is this possible?
And, like, the fact that it was a giant construction lot.
Like, I was, like, oh my god.
Like, after I travel back, like, I don't know, in the future or in the past or an alternate universe.
Oh my god.
Like, so, yeah.
So, that's my, that's my, that's my, one of my many stories.
Oh my god.
All right.
I'll tell you about my most unlucky day of my life so far.
I don't know why this happens every time I travel.
But, like, every time I travel, something will happen to me.
And, like, the whole time I was, like, it couldn't possibly get worse.
But, oh, absolutely it could.
And, like, I actually, I wrote down this adventure.
I had to take, like, a log note of everything that was happening to me, like, at that point.
All right.
So.
Um.
Okay, so, you know how I said that I decided super last minute that I was going to come over?
Because, you know, I thought for a long time about this.
Because I told you guys earlier that they invited me.
But, like, I was like, hmm, I don't know.
I don't know if I should go.
And then, at the last minute, I was like, you know what, fuck it.
It's the first land.
You know?
Maybe it'll be fun.
Maybe... By the way, I found out that no matter what land it is, I'm not really that interested in land.
I'll say it down.
So, like, I was like, oh, maybe it's because of Apex.
Like, um, you know, I don't play as a regular anymore.
So, like, maybe it was that.
But then I was like, let me test it out with Marvel Rivalists.
And then I watched it a little bit.
I was like, oh, no, I just... I'm just not a land person.
I just... I'm just... I'm just not a land person in general.
So, I need to, like, blow my nose.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't have tissues.
Let me text the staff person to be like, can you bring me tissues?
I need to blow my nose.
Um... Give me a sec.
Because I... Like I said, I got sick today.
This morning.
Of course, I did.
I was like, yippee!
I feel so healthy.
I need some tissues.
So, I can blow my nose.
Alright.
I messaged the staff person for it.
Um...
Anyway.
Um... Sorry.
Okay.
So... So, I decided super last minute.
But I had to, like, research stuff.
Because, like...
Um... I was like, okay.
Because they changed some laws regarding how to enter... How to enter China.
Because of, like... Like, I have a Canadian passport.
So, I looked up.
And I was like, oh, okay.
So... Because I couldn't get a visa.
Like, uh... Like, uh... A visa in time.
So, I was like, oh, can I still enter China without a visa?
And then there was, like... There is one thing.
And you just have to leave within 10 days.
So, I was like, oh, that works for me.
I'll just leave within 10 days.
And I looked it up to be like, okay, make sure that I got everything correct.
And I even, like, called, like, the airport company.
And be like, can I do this?
And they're like, oh, yeah.
No, you can.
As long as you do this and that.
And I was like, oh, sweet.
Cool.
Okay.
And then, and I even, like, called, like, my embassy to be like, hey, can I do this?
Can I just, like, uh, go there?
And then, like, leave?
At least as long as it's, like, within 10 days, I just leave?
And they're like, yeah, you can.
Because, like, it's a visa-free travel.
Like, and you're in one of the countries.
So, I was like, oh, sweet.
Cool.
Foreshadowing.
So, uh.
Because I wanted to be straight.
Because, like, there was no way I could get a, like, a 10-year visa done in time.
Um, because, like, you can get a 10-year visa.
Uh, but there was no way I could get.
Oh, my gosh, I really need to blow my nose.
Oh, okay.
Uh, yeah, that's okay.
Yeah, that's okay.
And also, okay.
No, I shouldn't ask for more.
I was like, can you also get me, like, a drink?
By the way, they give us free drinks and, like, tea and stuff.
So, like, I've been taking advantage of that.
Because it's paid, it's paid by net ease.
So, like, um, so I was just like, yippee.
Uh, I have water here.
I just want to blow my nose, really.
So, because I'm so stuffy right now.
Um, you are so demanding.
Okay, so.
All right, let me look through my logs.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, I'll tell you the story of one of my tissues here.
I can't.
I'm just like...
I want to blow my nose.
Oh, shit, sorry.
Guys, if you heard that, I was...
I leaned back a little bit.
Uh...
What else can I talk about?
Uh, before I tell you, like, the story.
Sorry, guys.
I leaned back and my headphone hit against my chair.
Uh...
I just used your shirt like a man.
Oh, my gosh.
I, like, scroll down and I have, like, so much...
So, messages of me just documenting one day.
Because I was sad and lucky.
Um...
Oh!
They gave me a labubu.
I got...
I finally have a labubu, guys.
I...
I got...
I got a labubu.
The Marvel Rivals staff was like, this is our present to you, Joki.
Here, have a labubu.
And they got me...
They got me a custom printed outfit, too.
For my labubu.
So, like, um...
Like, so, yeah.
Like, like, they gave me, like, like, an outfit where it's, like, a hoodie and pants.
So, he's not naked.
So, my labubu is not naked.
And, like, the hoodie says, Doki Braid.
That's...
And so, I have...
I have a labubu now.
It's my first one.
And my only one.
I'll show you guys.
I didn't take a picture of my labubu, but I took a picture of the outfit.
Wait, I can show you guys the outfit.
Let me see.
I know.
It's just so stuffy.
I don't...
I don't have tissues.
I didn't bring tissues.
I have...
Pop Drops, though.
Alright.
Let me see if I can find...
La la, babubu.
Oh, wait.
I want to show you guys this picture, though.
The staff helped me get a picture of this, and I need to show you guys.
I...
Okay.
Image.
They showed...
They got me this picture.
I am forever in their debt.
Let me...
Let me, uh...
Okay, you sort of tell what this picture is, but I still need to resize it.
But they got me this picture.
I'm so tired of you.
Look how tired me I am.
There's me.
I'm with Venom.
It's size accurate, guys.
No way.
It got grabbed.
The costume hides nothing.
It's so cool.
There's so many cosplay...
Like, they hire, like...
Uh...
Cosplayer groups to...
Go to the LAN event and cosplay and stuff.
And, uh...
So, like...
They had Doom.
I saw Doom.
Uh...
Squirrel Girl.
Psylocke.
Um...
Invisible Girl.
Sorry.
Invisible Woman.
Uh...
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Uh...
Hawkeye.
Star Lord.
I don't know.
And the rest.
I...
Ha ha ha!
I'm so tired.
And the rest.
Ha ha ha!
Oh my god.
Oh, I can't tell this story.
I wish I could.
But...
Ha ha.
There was some juicy drama and gossip.
During the LAN.
But I can't say it.
Ha ha ha!
I can't...
I can't say it though.
Ha ha ha!
It was funny.
I wish I could, guys.
I wish I could, but, like...
I'm...
I'm scared.
Ha ha ha!
Like...
Guys, I'm...
I can't.
Sorry.
I'm sorry for teasing you guys about this juicy gossip that I could never tell you.
Maybe in...
Remind...
Okay.
Add chat.
Remind me in two months to reveal the juicy gossip.
Because then I'd be back in Canada.
Remind me...
In two months.
I'll be back in Canada.
And, like...
People might have forgot about it.
So I could talk about it.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
And then I could talk about it.
Because people might have forgotten.
So then I won't get in trouble.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
It's a...
It's a pretty funny story, though.
It's pretty funny...
But...
I can't tell it now.
So...
Remind me in two months.
Ha ha ha ha!
No, it's nothing to do with doxing.
It's just a really funny story.
About, like...
Something that happened to...
Like...
For the content creators.
It's...
It's a really funny story.
But, like...
I don't think I can tell the story today.
I...
Ha ha ha ha!
They're gonna find you.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Where's my tissue?
Ha ha ha!
Please!
The more I talk, the more...
The more stuffy I get.
Where is it?
Ha ha ha ha!
Please!
I just want...
Tissue.
Oh yeah!
I was trying to be super incognito.
Because, like I said...
Um...
I decided to come...
Super last minute.
Uh...
So...
Because that I decided to come super last minute...
Um...
People didn't...
I had to join the...
Oh!
Thank you!
I...
Look, they got me.
They got me the thing.
I needed.
Oh!
Okay, I'm gonna do my stuff so I can blow my nose.
Give me a sec.
Okay, I'm back.
Okay.
Okay, what was I...
Okay, so...
I joined the...
The WeChat group.
Where it was, like, all the other content creators...
That were officially announced and everything.
So, like, where...
That everybody knew we're going.
And stuff, like, publicly.
So, then I was added...
Into the WeChat group.
But the thing is...
Like...
I've had a WeChat account for a very long time.
Because, like, that's how, like, I talked to...
Like, my parents and stuff.
So, like, you know, when WeChat was first, like, super...
Like, 10 plus years ago.
So...
The thing about that...
Is that...
Back then...
Um...
It's, like, user ID and stuff like that.
Like, you just know...
It was, like, first...
Before then...
Now it's, like, linked to your phone number, I think.
But before then, you can log in via user ID and stuff.
Because it was, like, a social media platform.
Like, it was just a messaging platform and stuff.
But now it's, like, even bigger.
So, because of that, my account had, like, a nickname that I used.
I had a nickname and everything on the account.
And also...
Um...
The profile picture is, like, something random.
So, like, people won't know who it is.
People...
People don't know who it is.
Because, like...
Because it was, like, literally some random person that joined into the...
Into the WeChat group.
So...
The thing is...
I came over late compared to the others.
I'll explain why.
Foreshadowing.
So, I came in late compared to the other people that arrived.
Because everyone was supposed to arrive at a certain time.
And I...
Like, um...
Or, like, around in the...
In the morning.
And I arrived at night.
Like, really late at night.
So, um...
So, uh...
So, people were like, man...
Hmm...
Who is this person in the Discord...
Like, in the WeChat group?
So, um...
Okay, let me see if I can...
Alright.
So, it's like...
Okay, sweet.
No one knows.
It's me.
No one knows I'm coming over.
That's the...
That's the best part.
As long as no one knows.
I'm gonna...
Uh...
As long as no one knows that I'm coming over, that's fine.
Because I didn't even want the content creators to know.
Because, like, you know, I'm, like, super paranoid and everything.
Like, I'm fine with, like, you know, staff.
Just because they're taking me around and everything.
But, like, you know...
I don't know a lot of these people.
The content creators.
I got invited.
So...
And they also had, like, plus ones and stuff, too.
That are coming.
And, like, I'm worried that, you know, they're taking photos and videos and stuff like that.
So like I didn't want them to know that like you know I'm here.
So I actually haven't met any of them because I've been like incognito and like doing my own thing.
So I was like sweet this plan is gonna work.
And then... I messaged in the Discord group.
Hey, so what about the portable Wi-Fi?
Anyway, with the badge of Jokey Bird.
I'm like, no!
My plan!
No!
So they all knew I was there.
They all knew that one of them is Jokey Bird.
One of us is Jokey Bird.
In the group chat, like they know I'm... they know I'm there.
They just don't know which one.
I blend right in.
But they know now.
They know.
This was... this was like... the... the... um...
This was literally like the day I arrived.
I covered, blown, abort the mission.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So...
So I was like, no!
I have my perfect plan!
So...
So they know I'm among them.
But they don't know which one.
I don't know.
They keep playing Among Us IRL.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Luca.
Okay.
All right.
Let me... I can tell you the story.
Okay.
So...
Back to this actual story.
Um...
The thing is...
So...
I was like...
Okay.
Cool.
I can come over.
And like...
As long as like...
Um...
I leave within...
Uh...
Three days.
I'm not sorry.
Leave within 10 days.
And...
Um...
Make sure...
I fly...
Like...
Out from the Guangzhou airport.
So...
My original ticket...
Was that...
I...
Fly from...
Hong Kong...
To...
Guangzhou.
Like the transit area.
And then...
From Guangzhou...
Back to Hong Kong.
So that was my original plan.
Anyway...
Onto the story.
Onto...
Onto the rest of the story.
So...
Um...
I missed my first flight.
Because...
I thought...
That...
The time...
Was at...
1pm...
Instead of...
1am.
And...
That day...
I had a lot of stuff to do that day.
So I had like...
I had to finish all my work stuff.
And so...
Because of that...
I...
Mixed up my...
Because I want to finish...
I had to finish a lot of work stuff before I go.
So...
Because like...
Obviously I still wanted to use this as a vacation.
So...
Because of that...
I was like...
Okay...
I'm just gonna stay up.
So I can just sleep on the plane too.
And in my head...
I like...
Thought...
Like...
Usually I would like...
Check...
Like...
Double check and be like...
Okay...
It's 1pm or 1am.
And I usually do that.
But I was so tired...
That I laid on my bed...
And just...
Disassociated.
Because I was so tired.
And then like...
And then I went back to work.
Um...
I got a message from staff being like...
Oh, we're gonna be picking you up...
Um...
At this time.
And I was like...
This does not add up.
Because my plane ride is like...
10 plus hours.
And then they're picking me up at this time.
Like...
I should...
I should be arriving...
They should be picking up later.
And so...
By the way...
By the time I discovered this...
It was 5 in the morning.
Because I was just staying up...
The entire day.
So...
It was 5 in the morning.
And then I looked up...
And I was like...
Oh my god.
Because they're using...
I don't use the 24 hour...
Like...
Clock time.
It's just like...
You know...
Like...
PM and AM.
But in Asia...
They use the...
They usually use the 24 hour clock.
So like...
That's why I didn't notice...
It said 1 AM.
I thought it was like...
1 PM.
Sorry.
But anyway...
Anyway...
I was like...
Um...
Okay...
Shit.
I guess...
But...
Because...
By the way...
I got business class.
Because...
I was not...
Going to...
Sit in economy...
For 10 plus hours.
I was like...
This is a vacation.
I'm gonna relax.
So in business class...
You can...
Readjust your flight.
Even if you miss your flight...
You can...
Um...
Get a new flight.
And...
Uh...
It won't charge you that much.
So...
It only charged me like...
50 dollars...
To get a new flight.
So I was like...
Oh...
Thank God.
I was like...
You know...
Oh my God.
Thank...
Fucking God.
I...
I did not have to...
Have to pay so much for a new flight.
And the new flight was like...
Within like...
Two or three hours.
So...
I didn't pack by the way.
I was planning on packing later.
And I didn't do laundry too.
So...
Cause I was planning on doing it...
Later.
Like...
I was literally planning on doing that like...
In like an hour or two.
And then they're like...
Okay.
The next flight has actually been two to three hours.
So you gotta get there.
So I was just like...
And I was like...
I'll do laundry.
I'll do laundry in Guangzhou.
It's fine.
I'll just do laundry there.
So...
So I like...
You know...
I got new clothes on, but then I packed some, like, dirty clothes in there because I was like, I'll do laundry in Guangzhou.
It's fine.
I did.
We get free laundry here.
And then I got there.
And I was like, okay, surely, surely, that's all the bad luck I don't have to deal with anymore.
Surely, that's, that's everything.
And then I got on the plane.
And the seat next to me was a four-month-old baby and his mother, who also brought her three-year-old daughter in business class.
And, you know, you do business class to avoid the situation.
And I swear to God, you're like, um, I swear to God, like, I knew it was like less than four months.
It was four months and under because it was a, it hasn't even opened its eyes yet.
And it was tiny as fuck.
Like, it was a tiny-ass baby.
And I was, there is no way that baby was older than four months because it hasn't even opened its eyes yet.
So, yeah, so, so I was like, okay, maybe I'm so fucking mentally and physically exhausted that I can just sleep through this.
Needless to say, I was very wrong because all that fucking baby did was cry and cry and cry.
I recorded it.
I will play this when I'm back.
I'll play the recording when I recorded the baby crying.
And I was literally like, please, someone do something in Minecraft.
I recorded the baby crying because all it did was cry.
Even, even when I, no, I had noise-canceling earbuds.
And even then, I could hear the baby.
Like, it's not, it's the type of baby crying where he, oh my god, where it's like, you know, they're crying because it's like a defense mechanism because they want, like, they need something.
And it's so, okay, so, um, she, I needed someone to know.
Yeah, yeah.
And, um,
so, so, I was just like, why did you bring your baby gear?
I was just like, why?
And I picked my seat, too.
I could have picked up, so there's, like, two, two sections.
I decided to get the back section because I wanted the window seat.
And because, like, the back section still had window seats, so I was like, okay, I wanted to, but the front section had no babies.
Anyway.
So, I got, like, I don't know, um, three to four hours, maybe, like, three to four hours of sleep.
But, which, by the way, I did not sleep for 24 hours before I got on that plane, too.
So, because, like, I purposely just wanted to, like, be exhausted and just, like, sleep on the plane because I really don't, I've been having, like, a fear of flying lately.
You know, I flew a lot back, like, growing up.
Like, I've been lately, um, developing a fear of flying.
So, like, to help that, I just wanted to sleep on the plane.
Just, like, be really tired and just sleep on the plane.
So, so, but then I only had, like, three to four hours of sleep.
So, I was, like, you know, not fucking there.
I'm like, I was not okay.
So, I got off the plane.
I'm in Hong Kong now.
Yeah, I'm in Hong Kong.
I was like, surely that's the end of it.
To my bad, horrible day.
That should be the last of it.
But, oh, past doki could not have been more wrong.
It was just getting started.
So, I'm, because it's a transfer from Hong Kong to Guangzhou, um, um, there, um, I had to, you know, check in again, um, in the Hong Kong airport.
So, when I checked in, when I checked in with my, like, uh, booking, um, at the, uh, by the way, I love, I use Cafe Pacific.
It's my go-to airline for anything.
If I could, if I can pick an airline, Cafe Pacific is my go-to airline.
And for those who don't know, they actually recently updated their business class.
So, like, their planes are so much better now.
Um, because they have, like, I used, I haven't used Cafe Pacific for a long time.
But they recently updated their planes.
So, it's actually crazy.
Like, um, they're, the, the plane, the planes they use now, it's so good.
Um, anyway.
So, I went to the, I went to the check-in booth.
And they're, like, where's your visa?
And I was, like, huh?
Oh, I'm using the visa-free, um, travel.
And they're, like, you can't do that.
I was, like, what do you, what do you mean?
I can't do that.
I called Cafe, I was, like, I called Cafe Pacific in Canada.
And my embassy, and they said it was okay.
And then that's why I came here.
And then they're, like, yeah, but you can't fly back to Hong Kong.
You have to fly back from a, to a, you have to fly to a different country.
I was, like, what?
What do you mean?
So, so, so, so the thing is, is that, when you fly back, it has to, it's the only way to use the visa-free travel.
Is it supposed to be a transit travel.
So, there's no direct flights from Guangzhou to where I live.
So, and the only way to get, uh, we have to do transit flights.
And I thought, and I called them to see if it's possible that Hong Kong is, like, can be, like, an exception for the transit travel to, like, um, go to Guangzhou, and then fly to Hong Kong, and then fly back to where I live.
And then, but you, you could do it, you could do it, you could do it when you're going to Guangzhou, but you can't do it when you're flying back.
So, I had to fly to a different country slash region.
So, I was, I was very lucky that my flight was not gonna, um, was not gonna be available until, like, like, four to five hours.
So, for an hour, for an hour, we were trying, me and Cafe Pacific were trying to figure out how to fix this.
Because they were like, do you have to go to Guangzhou right now?
And I was like, yes, I have to be there by today.
So, they were like, okay, because they were like, okay, you could stay in Hong Kong and try to get a visa now, like, there.
And then, like, go and get the visa.
And I was like, no, I actually have to go there, like, now.
So, so, and they're like, how about, like, and they're like, okay, what about you, like, um, fly, like, uh, you, like, um, uh, they're, like, trying to figure out, it's like, okay, how about, When you're in Guangzhou, you take a ferry ride to Macau, and then from Macau,
you fly to Hong Kong, and then from Hong Kong, you fly back to where I live.
And I was like, at that point, I was desperate.
I was like, I'll do anything.
Because they're like, okay, if you take a ferry to Macau, it's shorter counts.
So I was just like, I don't know, we were trying to figure out what to do.
And the thing is, they were saying, like, if it was anywhere but Guangzhou, we could have been able to fix this easily.
But because Guangzhou is so close to Hong Kong, like, we had to, like, do some fucking weird shit.
Because Guangzhou was so close to Hong Kong, so, like, they can't, like, adjust it so that I can fly back to Hong Kong.
They have to, like, I have to go somewhere else.
I have to go somewhere else.
And then, and then later on, they're like, okay, we don't think we can...
They're like, okay, maybe you shouldn't go to Macau, because we don't even know if you could do that.
Like, they're like, they're like, they gave me the plan, but they're like, we actually don't know if this actually works.
So maybe we should not do the Macau thing.
And so...
So...
Because they're calling everyone.
They're calling everyone, and they're like, trying to figure out what to do with me.
And because they're like...
And then later on, they're like, okay, you have...
Okay, you have to book a new flight to Guangzhou.
And then we have to cancel your return flight.
I was just like, what?
They're like, yes, because if we cancel your return flight, you won't be able to fly to Guangzhou right now.
Because it's linked.
The tickets are linked.
So...
I had to book a single ticket to go to Guangzhou.
Like, while...
Like, right now.
Like, my flight was literally in like, three hours.
So I had to book the flight right now.
Um...
So...
So I booked a flight right now.
And then like...
And then like, they canceled my tickets.
Oh no, they didn't.
Because then...
Okay, I'll...
I'll explain more.
I'll explain more later.
It's gonna be explained.
I booked a ticket.
A new ticket.
A new ticket!
But this time it's economy.
Because they're like...
Because I was just like...
There's no more seats.
So they're like, yeah, you're gonna have to book economy too.
So I was like, it's fine.
It's just an hour.
Okay?
It's just...
It's just an hour.
I could survive an hour in economy.
So...
And then...
They're like, you have to find a flight that flies out of country.
And then from there, a direct flight back to your home.
So then while I was there, I was like looking on...
And I was like, can you do that for me?
And they were like, no.
You have to do it yourself.
So...
And so I was like...
I was like on the phone.
Like I was like...
Because I was so stressed out.
Because I was like, I did everything to avoid the situation.
I was like...
On my phone.
And like trying to...
Trying to find like a flight.
And it was...
$3,000 more expensive than my original flight ticket.
Because I...
Have to fly...
To Tokyo.
It's like...
Wow, Doki.
That's so cool.
You get to have a Japan vacation.
No.
Because I can only stay in Tokyo.
For two hours.
And then I go...
Back home.
For a ticket that's $3,000 more expensive.
And I'm only in Tokyo for two hours.
And then I fly home.
And then...
So, I was like, okay, that should be it, right?
And I thought, you guys canceled my other tickets, right?
And they're like, no, you have to cancel your ticket yourself.
Call this number.
And I'm like, please, please, can you cancel my ticket for me?
Because I was so stressed out already.
I was like, can you cancel?
They're like, no, you have to call them yourself and do it.
So, then, I was like, but I thought you guys were gonna do it for me.
Like, we can't.
But you can get, like, a 3K refund.
I was like, yay.
At least I can get a 3K refund.
But then I also lose 3K for my new flight ticket because I have to fly to fucking Tokyo on business class.
I still have a net loss of 3K.
But at least it's not business class.
It's not even on Cafe Pacific.
I have to fly back.
Not even on Cafe Pacific.
I don't get my free food.
Anyway.
So, I called.
Got my refund.
Canceled my return.
My other return flight.
I thought that was it.
I thought it was over.
And I thought I was freed.
I was like, it can't get any worse than that.
I was wrong.
It most certainly can.
In ways I didn't think was possible.
So, there's more.
So, I waited for my flight.
I was supposed to be ready in 2 hours.
And I was like, yippee.
Can't wait to finally arrive to the hotel and relax.
Because the flight is only an hour.
I was like, that's weird.
It's 10 minutes till the flight is supposed to leave.
Why aren't we boarding?
Why are we all still sitting here?
We're supposed to leave in 10 minutes.
The flight got delayed.
But not only.
Did the flight get delayed.
It also moved to a different gate.
And if anyone has ever been.
To Hong Kong airport.
You know how big the airport is.
So, the gate changed from 40, number 40, to number 5.
So, I had to walk from gate 40 to gate 5.
Sorry, I hit the mic.
I'm sorry.
So, I was like, what happened?
So, I walked over there.
And I was like, okay.
That's fine.
That should be the last delay.
Right?
And then, I got to the new gate.
And then saw that it got delayed.
Again.
And I was like, oh.
But at least we get to stay here this time.
So, how long was this flight delayed from?
The flight originally was supposed to depart.
At 8 p.m.
It was supposed to depart.
And then it got delayed.
To boarding.
At 11 p.m.
And then.
I was messaging the staff.
And they were like, you know.
If you took a train ride.
From Hong Kong.
To Guangzhou.
It's like an hour.
So.
To recap.
I've been waiting in the airport.
For like four hours.
For my flight.
And then.
After that.
I waited.
Another three hours.
Because of the delay.
But that's not over.
It's not over.
So.
To be honest.
I have waited.
I have waited at the airport.
For like.
Maybe seven hours.
And.
All right.
So.
You think that was it, right?
Oh.
Oh boy.
Haha.
Oh man.
Today's just getting started.
Dragoons.
Okay.
So.
I was like.
Okay.
I'm hungry.
I'm so hungry.
I didn't eat dinner again, I'm just waiting here.
Anyway, so, they're like, the airport staff was like, we're so sorry for the delay.
Don't worry, we'll give you a 150 Hong Kong dollar voucher for any restaurant in the airport.
All you have to do is just let them scan your boarding ticket, and then it'll be included into, like, a free meal.
Worth, at least, worth, at most, $20.
Sorry, 150 Hong Kong dollars.
For those who don't know, the exchange rate for that, that's 20 US dollars for three hours of my time.
That's 20 US dollars for three hours of my time.
And I was like, okay.
At least, at least I get a free meal.
So, I decided, you know what?
I still have an hour left.
I'm gonna get my free meal.
And let me blow my nose real quick.
This is the intermission.
Alright, so, I found a restaurant.
And the meal was, like, less than $20.
So, I was like, sweet.
And I was so tired.
Okay.
Let me remind you.
I only slept three to four hours within the last, technically, two days.
It included, like, the 24 hours I stayed up to wait for this flight.
And also, the hours I was, I did not, I stayed up from, like, on that flight.
And then, two to Hong Kong.
So, like, I was so tired.
Mentally and exhausted.
And then, when I waited, I subconsciously brought out my Apple, my phone and just showed my Apple Pay.
And by the time, I realized, wait, no.
It's a free meal.
They scanned my phone.
So, I ended up paying 15 US dollars for my meal instead of my voucher.
Because all I had to do was bring out my boarding pass.
But instead, I brought out my phone.
Because, you know, you know, routine.
Like, you know, it's muscle memory.
So, I didn't get my free dinner.
And you must be thinking, oh, well.
Doki, why didn't you buy something?
I was, I did not want to eat anymore.
I don't, I don't know what to tell you guys.
I really just did not want to eat anymore.
I was, I ate so much.
I don't need more food.
I, I, I...
I couldn't even finish my paid meal.
That forgot to get for free.
I couldn't even finish it.
I didn't want to, there was just nothing.
It was, it was pointless.
It was pointless at that point.
I've accepted it.
I, I was just done.
I...
Anyway.
You thought that was over, right?
Well.
So, I got up.
I got up from my chair.
I've already paid because I paid when I was ordering Namiya.
And I forgot there were stairs.
There were two stairs.
Because the restaurant was like heightened a little bit.
I thought it was a ramp, but it was two stairs.
And this is where fall damage came in.
And, well, technically, I should have been able to stop myself with my two hands.
But, coincidentally, one hand was carrying a bag of gifts that I was going to give to the Marvel Rivals staff that I bought in the airport.
The other hand, I was holding my phone.
And then my bag had my laptop in it.
So, there was a lot of front weight going on.
So, I couldn't cushion my fall with my arms or my head.
So, I landed straight down on my legs.
Like, hard.
And then nobody held me up.
I was like...
So, my right leg was filled with, had like bruises.
And then, and then like, my left foot, I semi-sprayed my left foot.
But, I couldn't rest because they're boarding.
So, I was, I was hobbling to the gate because the gate, the gate was like a little bit far because I had to walk to the restaurant.
So, I was like hobbling back to the gate.
Like, I was like, I gotta make it.
I gotta make it.
Bro, okay.
The fake, the fucked up thing is that it still hurts.
My right leg, if I touch the bruises, I, it hurts.
Like, I, like, that's how painful I landed on my legs.
Like I said, I couldn't cushion my fall with my hands because one hand literally had like a bag filled with like, like, like snacks and stuff that I bought for the staff.
And then my left hand was my phone, so I couldn't cushion at all.
So, like, all the momentum went towards my legs.
And fall, so that's when I learned fall damage exists, guys.
Fall damage exists.
And I was just like, I was like hobbling back to the gate.
Alright.
And then you think, well, that's surely, surely that's, surely that's, that's, I thought that was the last thing that was gonna happen to me.
And then I made my tweet because I was like, it's over.
I'm gonna get on that plane and everything's gonna be fine.
That's, and I, and I tweeted, I tweeted.
And I was like, this is it.
This, this is the last thing.
And my day will be over because I'm boarding now.
And so, and so, and so, I was, I was, I was ready.
I was on the plane.
I was, I got the middle seat too.
That's how fucked up it was with me booking this ticket.
Literally, like, a new economy ticket.
All they had left was the middle seat in between two other guys.
So, I had that middle seat, like, in between two people.
And, and then, so I was like, okay, that's fine.
I'm on the plane.
I'm finally on the fucking plane.
Like, after two delays, I'm finally there.
And then the guy, the pilot, was like, uh, good morning, everybody.
Uh, it seems that we're gonna have a slight delay because, uh, there, it seems to be thunder outside.
And in my head, I was like, oh my god, am I gonna die?
So, so, so, so, so.
So, so, so, so.
So we had to sit on the plane and wait a little bit more.
And it was delayed.
It was delayed again while I was on the fucking plane because I was like, okay, I mean, maybe, Maybe, at least even though it's late, maybe the thunderstorm will be gone.
That's a good tradeoff.
Anyway, the plane finally was going to take off.
And then, the pilot was like, uh, hello everybody.
Thank you for flying, Cafe Pacific.
It seems that there's going to be some turbulence because we're going to be flying in a thunderstorm.
So if you see the fastened seatbelts, remember to make sure your seatbelts are fastened.
I'm like, what do you mean we're flying in a thunderstorm?
Wait, what's the point of delaying for a thunder if we're still going to fly in a thunderstorm?
What's the point?
Wait, what's the point?
In my head, I was like, oh my god, I'm going to die.
I'm going to fucking die.
This is not a good day for me.
This is not a good day.
This could actually happen any other day.
I'll say that jokingly.
But today, today, everything is happening.
This is going to be the day.
Because I was like, everything happened.
I won't even be surprised if I'm on Google search.
So, I was actually freaking out.
Because I was like, oh my god, we're flying in a thunderstorm.
Oh my god.
The signs are all there.
The entire... The world was telling me to not board that flight.
And I still... The world was telling me not to fly over.
And I kept pushing on.
This is my punishment.
Right here.
And then...
And what did not fucking help was the guy to my left who was sitting on the window seat.
He had the window seat open.
Like, the windows open.
And he was taking fucking selfies and pictures of the fucking thunderstorm that was happening outside while the turbulence was going on.
I was like, please, sir.
Please, we don't need this.
We just closed the fucking window.
Like, oh my god.
While we were in turbulence.
Like, it was so... I was like, bro.
And then he was like, taking selfies and photos of outside.
I could see the thunder and he was taking photos.
I...
And then...
I just... I just sat there and looked at the TV and looked at the elevation.
Because there's...
On the TV...
There's like...
Like, you could see, like, where your plane was flying to.
Or like, the direction your plane is flying to.
And like, how close you are to...
To the final destination.
And also the elevation and stuff like that.
So like, I was just looking at it.
And I was like, I couldn't sleep.
You don't understand.
After everything, I...
I couldn't sleep.
Because I was like, if I'm gonna die, maybe I could die in my sleep.
But I can't.
There was no...
I can't.
Not with this fucking turbulence.
Not with it.
So...
Every time the elevation goes down, I was like, this is it.
This is...
Oh my god.
The elevation is going down.
This is it.
And then, I freaked out a little...
Okay.
This is where I freaked out a bit.
Just a little bit.
But...
When...
When, like...
We took off.
Because like...
The...
It takes 30 minutes.
It takes 30 minutes to fly from Hong Kong to Guangzhou.
That's how close.
And...
And so like...
We took off.
And then literally five minutes later...
The pilot was like...
Cabin crew.
Go to your seats.
We're getting ready for departure.
We're getting...
Gonna get ready for landing.
And I'm like...
What do you mean we're getting ready for landing?
We just took off.
Are we doing an emergency landing?
What do you mean?
I don't like...
We've been in the air...
Like, for, like, five to ten minutes.
What do you mean we're getting ready for landing?
I don't understand.
I don't...
Nani?
Like...
So, but yeah, so, like, everything was in my head.
Anyway, I landed safely in Guangzhou.
Despite flying through a thunderstorm.
And then you think, well...
Surely...
I was like, I'm here.
I'm alive.
I'm in Guangzhou.
I'm here.
So, if you've ever, um, went through immigration in China, you would know how fucking long it is, how long it takes, and how long the lines are.
So...
I line up.
I had my, like, um, arrival sheet done already.
And everything.
Because I did it on the plane.
And then...
So...
Um...
It takes, like...
It took me... I was in the line...
For...
I think, 40 minutes.
I was in the line for 40 minutes.
And then finally, I got up to the immigration officer.
And he was like...
Where's your visa?
I was like...
Oh, I'm visa-free.
I'm leaving within 10 days.
And they're like...
No, no.
You need a visa.
If you're entering Guangzhou.
And I was like...
No, no, no.
Here's my flight ticket to Tokyo.
See?
I'm gonna fly to Tokyo.
After.
See?
Visa-free.
I...
They said I can.
And then they were like...
Oh, you're on the wrong line.
Oh, sorry.
You're actually on the wrong line.
So...
There's a special line.
For the visa-free...
Uh...
Travelers.
They're heading over.
And...
And you can't really see it.
Because it's like...
All the way...
Far right.
It's far right.
And like...
It's a tiny sign.
So the foreigner line...
Is far left.
And...
The visa-free line...
Is very far right.
With a very tiny sign.
And then when I got there...
There was no line.
There was literally one person.
There was literally...
One person...
Manning the booth.
By the way...
When I was in the other line...
I was fucking...
I was...
I arrived at 2 in the...
I don't even know.
I arrived at like...
I don't know.
It was like 1 or 2 a.m.
I...
1 a.m.
There was 1 a.m.
They're...
Like they were closing booths and...
Like I was seeing them closing more and more terminals.
Because it was so late.
So like...
It was like 5 that started...
And then went to 2.
Like...
I just seen them closing more and more terminals.
So it got slower and slower.
Anyway.
So then I went to the far right.
And I decided...
Like I had to write a new form...
For it.
Oh sorry.
Is my mic...
I'm sorry.
I'm going through a lot.
I'm sorry for peeking.
I'm sorry everyone.
My mic is peaking a lot.
It's a very...
It's a very sensitive story for me.
I...
I get...
I was very emotional.
I had to keep this...
I had to keep this quiet.
I...
Just let me...
Drama dump just a little bit more guys.
I had to keep this all in.
Until I revealed that I was in Guangzhou.
I didn't want to say anything until I...
I did my big reveal.
And...
So...
I...
Went to this...
The new...
The new area.
I gave them my passport.
And everything.
And then they were like...
Show me your hotel booking.
And I was like...
Huh?
They were like...
We need proof that you are staying at this hotel.
And I was like...
Oh, my friend booked it for me.
I...
They never sent me a confirmation...
Thing about it.
Cause they booked it for me.
And...
They're like...
Okay...
Well...
Message your friend for it.
And by the way...
It was like...
1.30 in the morning.
It was...
But...
So I was like...
So...
I messaged the staff.
And I was like...
I need the confirmation letter.
I need like the receipt.
And the main person that booked my hotel...
Was asleep.
So the staff...
Had to...
Call the hotel.
So they could send...
The...
Receipt over...
To them.
And they could send...
To me.
And then while we were waiting...
The lady...
Was like...
Like...
Just staring at me.
And I was just standing there.
Mad emoji.
And she was just standing there.
She was just sitting there.
Mad emoji.
Back at me.
And we were just looking at each other.
Awkwardly.
And I'm like, I'm sorry, they're like, trying to get it right now.
And then, and then, and then, and then, she was like, yeah, literally, literally, the green mad emoji, that was us.
And then, and then she was like, do you still have your Hong Kong ID?
And I was like, no.
She's like, are you sure?
I was like, yeah, I'm sure.
She was interrogating me.
I was like, please, I'm not, please, I'm not, I swear, I'm not doing anything illegal.
And then, later, we're still waiting.
And I need to blow my nose real quick.
Later, we're still waiting.
And then she looked at me in the eye and was like, you didn't book your hotel, did you?
I was like, no, I swear, I swear, they're sending me the hotel right now.
I swear, I swear, I know.
And then, and then they're like, and I was like, and then I got, and I got the, and then I got the confirmation.
See, the moment she was like, you didn't book the hotel, did you?
I was like, no, I did, I swear, and then I got, I was like, bing, bing, here's the hotel confirmation.
And then I was like, here's the hotel receipt.
And then, and then I'm like, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, and, um, and then I was freed.
They freed me from immigration.
I was, I got to leave.
I didn't get, I didn't get detained and sent back home.
And I got, I, I was freed.
And I went to find my luggage.
And like, thank God, the moment I got there, when, like, it was just like three bags left, and one of them was my bag.
And on the screen, it was, it said like, oh my God, what did it say on the screen?
You know, in the, on the screen, it was says, coming to an end, luggage claim.
So it literally was about to end for that, for that, like, plane.
And they would have, like, confiscated the luggage.
It was like, coming to an end.
So I got my luggage just in time before that happened.
And then, and then, I, like, met the staff, and I told, I was like, I'm freed.
Doki is free.
And they're like, oh my God, I can't believe you had to go through all that.
And I was like, how long have you guys been waiting for me?
And they were like, five hours.
They're like, we've been waiting for you for five hours at the airport, ever since the delay.
And I'm like, I'm so sorry.
I'm so...
So, and that was my most unlucky day of my life.
So far.
Oh no.
For now.
That was my most unlucky day.
Don't say that.
I don't know how I'm functioning as an adult.
Guys, I don't know how I get through life in general these days.
I don't know.
God is trying so hard to be like, you should not be alive.
But I'm still here.
I'm still here, guys.
TokiBur did a terrible, horrible, no good, very bad day.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yeah, that was day one.
That was day one, chat.
Why I had a terrible day that day.
You guys didn't think it could get worse, right?
It's like you're crazy.
I literally thought I was going to die in the thunderstorm.
I thought it was going to be a fucking statistic.
I was like, why are we still flying?
What the fuck?
Why would you tell us we're going to fly in the thunderstorm?
Like, what's wrong with you?
Please, no part two.
Okay.
So what we learned from this experience...
Maybe I shouldn't decide to go to China, like, or travel anywhere, like, two days before my actual trip.
Maybe I...
Maybe I shouldn't, like, go overseas, like, two days before I actually go overseas, guys.
I think that's, like, a good idea to do.
I think maybe I...
But after that, I've had a lot of fun.
After that, I had so much fun, though.
It's been really fun here so far.
The food has been so good, though.
I love... oh my gosh, I took so much pictures.
I'll show the pictures when... I'll show food pictures.
I'll show some more food pictures when I get back, when I have my skin suit.
Um, and... but, yeah, dude, I took... oh my gosh, the food is great.
I went to the biggest mall in Guangzhou.
It's, like, crazy.
They have, like, four fucking...
Okay.
They have, like, four...
Miniature, like, zoos in there, like, for some miniature animals.
I was like, what the fuck?
It was, like, seven... seven floors and everything.
It's... it's crazy.
And I'm gonna see pandas later today, too.
So, uh, I'm gonna go to another...
I'm gonna go to, like, the biggest zoo, uh, here.
I think... I don't know.
There's so many zoos here.
But I'm gonna go see pandas.
And there's, like, so many pandas.
And I don't wanna see a panda.
That's really it.
And then, like, eat good shit.
I'm gonna eat good shit.
I'm gonna...
Oh my gosh.
I don't know if I can say I'm gonna eat that.
Because, like, it's illegal in America.
Guys, can I get a pass to eat foie gras?
Guys, I love foie gras.
I know, I know, guys, I know that foie gras, there's some, you know, you know, it's bad in America, but so good.
Why is it so wrong, but so good at the same time?
Why is it so bad?
No, it is, foie gras is bad in the states, I'm pretty sure.
Did they legalize it again?
I know, oh, wait, they legalized it back?
It used to be bad, I remember.
Was it not?
No, it was.
I remember it was.
I remembered it was.
Yeah, it's illegal in, it's illegal in some states in America.
But yeah, apparently, I was told there was a really good foie gras place.
I know foie gras is French, but like, but like, we love foie gras.
And like, um, and like, there's a really good foie gras place, like here.
I was told, I'm gonna eat one time, guys, I swear.
It's my one pass.
Guys, I had a bad day.
I had a bad day.
And I, I guess that duck's gonna have a bad day, too, because I'm gonna eat it.
Equivalent exchange.
We both had bad days.
But like, I'm gonna eat something to cure my bad day.
I'm gonna eat it.
No.
Go eat it.
One duck must...
Pain for pain.
This is my one pass.
I've had foie gras in a long time.
I haven't...
You know...
Two wrongs doesn't make a right, Doki.
I had to do so many wrongs, so...
This is my pass.
The one bird shall be sacrificed to bring balance to my day.
Well, yeah, guys.
Don't travel overseas.
Last minute.
That's my tip of the day.
I thought, I don't know, I thought it'd be easier.
I even called and everything.
I didn't know how difficult it'd be.
They said it'd be fine.
I even Googled.
I...
But I've been having a good time, though.
The staff have been, like, super nice to me.
And, like, um...
I saw Guan Guan, who is, like, the head dev of Marvel Rivals.
And, like...
I didn't take a picture with him, though.
But, like, I saw him.
And, uh...
I saw, like, a bunch of...
A bunch of, like...
What is it called?
Like, a bunch of, like, cool stuff around the campus, too.
I saw fucking peacocks, guys.
And, like, the staff took me to a lot of cool places, too.
And, like, to a lot of places to eat.
Which is the best part.
Honestly, the food is the best part so far.
Um...
Maybe the pandas will also be my top three.
But...
I haven't seen the pandas yet.
But so far...
So far...
Um...
Love...
Love the food.
And it's been great.
It's been really fun.
Um...
Never flying to see Toki again.
How did my...
My flying story traumatized everyone?
It was like...
Well, now I'm never gonna fly again, too.
Everyone's, like, traumatized now.
Yeah.
Um...
But, yeah.
Freeho...
They put me on, like...
The V...
Oh, it's so funny.
Okay.
Apparently, I found out that, like...
Um...
We're in the same hotel.
Like, the content creators and, like...
Influencers...
Are in the same hotel as, like...
The...
The players.
But the players got the...
The...
Like, the lower floors.
And, like, the lower regular...
Rooms.
And then, like...
All the content creators and influencers...
Got the VIP rooms.
Like...
I was like...
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
I got a fucking king-size bed.
Yeah.
And I don't even need to...
Oh, yeah.
Do a watch party.
I'm here on vacation.
Technically, I paid for my own flight.
Okay.
I paid for my own flight.
But...
The Marrival staff paid for, like...
My hotel.
My travel.
Like, my...
Like...
Like, Guangzhou travel stuff.
Like, you know...
Ordering DDs for me.
And, um...
You know...
Food and drinks.
And stuff like that.
Oh, my God.
Like...
Um...
I forgot.
So, one of the staff recommended me a place to eat.
And then, they were like...
Oh, um...
This is really good.
Like, we all love to go here.
And I was like...
Oh, cool.
And then...
So...
Obviously, we have to scan a QR code.
And I was like...
Well...
I don't know...
What...
I don't know what this says.
I can't access it.
So, I, like...
Screenshot the QR code.
And sent it to the staff.
And I was like...
Can you order for me?
And then, she was like...
Yeah, no problem.
And then...
Um...
And then, like...
Uh...
Like, she...
She, like...
Ordered all the food for me.
And it was a lot of fucking food.
And I was like...
Holy shit.
And then, like...
I tried to pay.
And I didn't know...
What the lady was trying to say to me.
And I was like...
Sorry, I'm Canadian.
Because I didn't...
I didn't know what she was saying.
I was like...
I was like, why can't I pay?
I'm so confused.
Why isn't she accepting my payment?
Like, hello, scan my WeChat receipt.
And then, and then I, like, messaged the staff.
I was like, did you pay for my mail?
I don't know what she's saying, but, like, she won't accept my payment.
And the staff was like, oh, yeah, yeah, I paid for your mail.
So, I was like, oh my god, I couldn't understand.
I have selective hearing for certain words.
Because, like, it's easier for me to listen to Cantonese than it is to listen to Mandarin.
Because, like, a lot of words, like, Cantonese, there's, like, a lot of words don't really overlap sometimes in Mandarin.
So, when they say some words that I don't understand, I lose context for the entire sentence.
So, I was so confused.
I was like, what do you, I, what?
What is she saying to me?
But, yeah, the staff paid for my meals.
Even when I was going out by myself to eat, which was super nice.
I was like, yay, free food.
Yippee.
Yay.
What other, what other, uh, what other stuff happened?
Um, oh my god.
And one of them have a corgi.
They showed me their corgi.
I sat in a car with their corgi.
It was so cute.
He was, like, 12 years old.
And his name is, like, Pansu.
Or, I think, I don't know.
I don't, actually, why did you doxing her dog, Doki?
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure that's not his name either, too.
Ha ha ha ha.
Look, look, I'm pretty sure I don't even actually remember his name.
I was drunk.
I had beer.
I just, I was, I had, like, a dinner with, like, some of the staff members.
Like, they were treating, like, we were drinking beer and everything.
I'm not, I was, like, drunk.
I don't even think I remember the dog's name.
I just made up a name for him.
Ha ha ha ha.
But I remember he was 12 years old.
Because I was like, holy shit, he's old.
Oh!
Wait.
Oh, we, like, um, the staff members, like, one of the staff members' husband was feeding some stray cats, like, the meat that we were eating.
Like, we had, like, takeout for some of the meat.
Okay, wait.
Um.
Um, let me see if I could find it.
I was like, oh my god, look at him go.
But this is, like, this is one of the staff members' husband, um, like, feeding the stray cat.
Let me see if I can save it.
I was, yeah, I got a, I got a picture of it.
Because I thought it was cute.
I was like, look at that.
Look at that.
Look at that cat.
Let's see.
Oh, this is a big picture.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Look!
Look at him!
He's feeding the cat!
There are so many stray cats here, by the way.
There's, like, you're talking toxing this cat.
We gave this cat fucking good ass meat.
That's for sure.
We gave, we gave this cat some good ass fucking meat.
Yeah!
There are so many kitties around.
There's, like, a lot of campus cats, too, around the NetEase campus, too.
Which is pretty cool.
Um, whatever stuff can I show you guys.
Oh, I'm getting a little lightheaded.
I'm not.
I'm sick, guys.
So, I'm, like, I'm so...
Oh, let me show you, uh, I've been talking a lot.
I don't think I was supposed to talk this much.
I literally woke up.
I was, like, oh, no.
Oh, no.
I want to see my pandas.
Oh, wait, here.
Here we go.
Here's, like, my...
Oh, yeah.
I forgot.
Let me show you guys the LaBubu...
The LaBubu outfit that they got me.
My first LaBubu outfit.
Look at this.
He has pants.
This is my...
I didn't put on my LaBubu yet.
But they got me...
They gave me a LaBubu and a custom Donkey Bird outfit.
Like...
It's for my LaBubu.
It looks just like Donkey Bird.
The Donkey LaBubu.
Yeah, they got me this.
And then...
What else?
What else can I show you guys?
Uh...
Let's see.
I'm trying to see what I can show you guys.
Oh, yeah.
I'll show...
Wait, okay.
This is, like, the picture I took when we were arriving and being, like...
When I was, like, arriving to Hong Kong.
And I was, like, nothing's gonna get worse from then on.
Everything's gonna go, okay.
Little does she know.
This is when I...
I looked up.
I was, like, there's Hong Kong.
Surely nothing's gonna get worse.
Oh, my gosh.
I was so hopeful.
Back then, I was...
Filled with so much joy.
Little does she know.
Things are not gonna go okay for the rest of that day.
Um...
Last photo before disaster.
Yeah.
So...
There's this photo.
And then, uh...
She doesn't know.
She...
Oh, yeah.
By the way, the LAN is actually...
This LAN, the background, is actually in the campus.
This is in NetEase Studios.
Um...
So, like...
Uh...
There's no actual, like, audience.
Like, I mean, there is audience.
But it's, like, staff.
Like, NetEase staff.
Uh...
Company.
Like, the NetEase staff.
Like, family and friends.
And, like, other, like, invited guests and stuff.
So...
Um...
Yeah, I peaked at getting the window seat.
That was the best part of my entire day.
Uh...
So...
And the entire LAN event is hosted within...
One of the...
Within, like...
One of the floors of the building.
So, like...
I was like, that's crazy.
Because it, like...
You know...
That was so much production stuff.
For, like, just one room.
You know?
Um...
But, yeah.
That's, like, the arena.
Wait.
And then...
Uh...
What else can I show you guys?
Oh, wait.
I forgot.
I have a very important photo to show you guys.
I forgot to show.
I have a very, very, very important photo.
Give me a sec.
This is very important.
I specifically requested the staff to get this photo for me.
I...
Apparently, there's videos, too.
But they haven't sent me the videos yet.
But...
I asked the staff to get me this...
That's right.
Jealous.
My Marvel rival wife.
You're my main.
That's right.
I got my main.
Give me a kiss.
That's looking great.
But, yeah.
They even got a video for me, too.
Oh, yeah.
So...
You guys didn't see?
See this photo?
Only I got this photo.
Okay.
Not this one.
But, like, all the other content creators got, like, a photo of the cosplayers.
But...
It should have been me.
But this photo.
This photo?
Okay.
Technically, I wasn't even supposed to get this photo.
Because none of the content creators are allowed in this room.
Like, none of the invited people, players, or whatever.
They're not allowed in this dev room.
Because this room where they take pictures or film the dev updates.
You know, where, like, Wong Wong sits on the chair and be like, Today, we're gonna, we're gonna launch the patch updates and stuff like that.
And the thing is, um...
Um, if you watch the dev, like, you know, the dev update video, This is literally the same, this is the same area.
But no one's allowed in there.
Unless you're, like, a developer or, like, a staff member.
Because the room is actually for, like, is, like, where they're actually working and stuff.
Like, doing, like, updates and stuff.
Like, working on the new Marvel Rivals stuff.
So they didn't want things to get leaked, you know?
Um, so, but the thing is, um, they let me...
And the thing is, they have to, like...
There's, like, desks originally on here and everything.
So they have to set up, like, a photo shoot for this in general, too.
So they have to move the desk around.
And so they have, like, the perfect angle and everything.
And so, I was allowed to have a picture.
Because all I had to do was just give them the plushie.
That's it!
So I don't need to be in there.
I just gotta give them me.
I might give them the plushie.
And they set this whole thing up for me.
So I'm, like, the only content creator that got this photo because of it.
Because I was, like...
Yeah, I got the doki privilege.
Because they literally, like, set up their...
It's literally their office.
This whole thing...
The developer update is filmed in their office.
And they have to, like, actually, like, move the desk and stuff around to take this photo and film it.
Um, because I asked.
I was, like, you know, the worst thing they can say is no.
And they're, like, no, we can do it.
We can help you get this photo.
And I was waiting for so long, too, for this photo.
Because that photo was going to be my big reveal that I'm here.
So I was waiting for so long.
This was my big reveal.
This is why it took so long for me to tweet.
Because this was the photo that I wanted to reveal that I was in China.
So, you know, I had to hold on my trauma until then, until I got the photo.
And I'm really thankful for the staff for setting that up.
Because, you know, it was a lot of work, you know, setting that photo up.
Because they even photoshopped the picture to look just like the dev update, too.
To have, like, the lighting and everything.
Like, this, apparently they photoshopped this picture for me, too.
To make it look, like, exactly like the dev update.
Um, you know, because when they're filming it, they do, like, lighting stuff.
So I'm like, yay!
So, yeah.
Anyway.
That's some of my stories.
I have a lot of stories.
But that's, I'm tired now.
I've talked a lot.
And, like, I'm getting a little lightheaded.
I'm actually, I was like, okay, stream for two hours and you're good.
I'm getting a little lightheaded now.
So I'm going to rest.
Anyway, guys.
My next stream.
I'll be back in Canada.
Um.
I'll tell you when.
But that will be my next stream.
And I hope you guys refilled your Dokium.
And, um, that you remember me.
And that wasn't a statistic, guys.
Alright.
I'm going to see some pandas today.
Yippee.
Anyway, guys.
I'll show you guys more photos.
Because I didn't actually, like, look through my photos that I wanted to send.
Because, like, I was, you know.
I was trying to figure out how to get my skin suit to work for an hour plus.
But, and yet, it didn't fucking matter.
So, thank you all for the super chats.
And the, the, the gifted memberships.
And membering.
And everything.
I really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you for subscribing.
And, uh, I'll see you guys later.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause your check.
Get them around.
Get that blood flow.
And if you step for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye.